YARD:
You know what I love? Weddings.
Do you know what I don't love?
Slavery.
When I read
that it's now trendy
for white people to have
lavish plantation weddings
on estates where black people
used to be enslaved,
that (bleep) didn't sit right
with me.
So to figure out
if this is actually as racist
as it sounds,
Robin Thede and I traveled
to the Richwood Plantation
in Kentucky
to sit down
with owner Colleen Sutton
under the guise
of planning our own wedding.
-Great place.
-It's so beautiful here.
Thank you very much.
Is it okay that I'm inside?
-Absolutely.
-Okay.
As we understand,
this place has some...
-very interesting history also.
-It does.
Samuel Fern is the owner
that is really,
um, credited
to building this property.
-He had slaves, right?
-He did.
There were three slaves
that were recorded.
But it was recorded earlier
-that he did actually have
four slaves, -Four slaves.
-and, um...
-What happened to the other one?
He... did... f...
es-escape, I guess.
-He actually...
he actually ran away. -Yay...!
♪ ♪
Colleen gave us a tour
of the land,
and surprisingly, I didn't feel
the urge to run away.
So, you want to know what
one of the most ironic things
about where
we're standing right now?
-That we're not working?
-(Sutton laughs)
Is look how close we are
to the river.
Kentucky was a slave state.
That's Indiana--
and that was a free state.
Wait a minute, wait a minute,
wait a minute, wait a minute.
-You had a slave living
right here... -Yes, sir.
-staring at freedom every day.
-Yes. Absolutely.
-Wow. -That's how committed
black people are
to not swimming, is that
we would rather stay slaves
-than swim 50 yards to freedom.
-That is... Well, you know.
But that's not to say I
didn't see anything suspicious
on the property.
Hey, Colleen, what's that?
YARD: It looks like a place
to hang black people.
Uh, no. Actually, I think
it was more of a pulley system,
where they were able
to bring heavy objects
from down low up to
the third floor of the mansion.
-Oh, like black people?
-Oh, I love that.
No, not like black people.
How authentic
can these weddings get?
Right? So if we want to have
a plantation wedding,
I mean,
how authentic can they get?
Do we dress in costume?
Like, what can go on?
You can really do
anything that you want.
You can be as elaborate
and do something
like a traditional
plantation wedding...
Traditional...
1790... traditional?
-Absolutely.
-Because we're gonna dress up
our little cousins, like,
you know, little slaves,
-little... little (bleep)
running around. -Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
-Aw...
And we might beat 'em.
-With, like, Nerf whips.
-Everybody take turns.
-Not real whips.
-Yeah, not real whips.
Yeah, that doesn't...
that doesn't feel good to me.
If we have our wedding here,
and let's say she gets pregnant
wedding night--
-'cause it's gonna be on--
-Yeah.
-um, do you keep the baby,
or...? -(laughing)
What do we do?
-No. -Is it ours?
Can we leave with it?
Absolutely. Yes.
I'm... I am the owner
of the property,
-I am not the owner of you.
-Of us. Yeah.
Oh. Well,
that should be on the sign.
Our approach might have been
too traditional for Colleen,
so we sat down
with a black person
to see how they would feel.
Cuita, you actually catered
weddings at this plantation.
-Yes.
-How do you feel about that,
having a wedding
on a plantation?
I actually don't see
an issue with it.
So if you had a contract
that said that...
we want
an all-African American staff
and we want to call you all
the N-word...
-But you get paid.
-in the spirit...
-but you get paid...
-$10,000 for the day.
Right. And it's just in the
spirit of the antebellum world.
-No.
-THEDE: No.
-No money's gonna allow...
-$20,000 a day. $20,000.
-I don't think I could put
a price... -$35,000.
-I wouldn't put a price on it.
-$50,000.
-No. -A million dollars.
-A hundred thousand dollars.
-A million dollars.
-That's a lot of money.
They could probably call me
(bleep) for... a million!
(laughs)
Now, a lot of people think
it's bad to get married
at a plantation,
given its history.
Do you think that's valid?
I think there is validity there,
but I think that if we were to
look at our nation as a whole,
there are so many places
that evil has happened
that we wouldn't have anywhere
to do incredible events.
But just because bad (bleep)
happens everywhere,
doesn't mean we
should just forget about it.
I'm all for having weddings
at plantations
as long as we Keep It 100
about its past.
Let me do something that I
would have never been able to do
back in the day,
and that's speak my mind.
Richwood Plantation
is beautiful.
And here,
white people serve you.
-Yes! -Whoever thought
we'd live to see this day?
(laughs): Who'd have thought
we'd live to see any day?
We're on a (bleep) plantation!
(laughs)
But I got to admit,
I love white people serving me.
♪ ♪
(cheering, applause)
YARD:
I'm not eating that (bleep).